the coronavirus is forcing all of us to
protect ourselves from germs
and that means more masks gloves and
wipes but it also means more trash
laura podesta explains how our personal
protective equipment could hurt the
environment
a byproduct of the coronavirus crisis is
this trash problem
it definitely grosses me out to see all
that
trash that you know who knows what germs
it has on it
discarded sanitizer bottles gloves and
face masks often end up on the streets
creating both a biohazard and an
environmental hazard
no one wants to touch ppe litter right
so people are afraid that it's
contaminated
so that means they're not picking it up
from the streets mark benfield is a
professor in the department of
oceanography at louisiana state
university
he's been tracking ppe litter around the
country since the pandemic began
benfield says masks or gloves washing
into sewers is a major
concern they'll end up in our waterways
where the plastic can break down
and eventually be ingested by small
aquatic animals
if a human being eats a fish that's
consumed lots of smaller animals
then those pollutants can get into our
bodies
to combat the problem the mayor of
houston recently launched an
anti-litter campaign called don't let
houston go to waste
the city will hold cleanup events that
will target illegal dumping
and in los angeles anyone caught
dropping a mask or glove
could be fined 250 bucks but many are
finding the solution lies with our
choices
like wearing a reusable mask these
things are
run like 20 bucks a pop so i'm not going
to throw it on the ground anywhere
others say they're speaking out and i
say something
all the time like can you pick that up
garbage cans right there
and gently reminding their neighbors the
location of the nearest trash can
laura podesta cbs news new york
in new york city staff are trying to
educate the public about ppe waste
they've started posting reminders about
proper disposal near hospitals bus
stations and grocery stores to try and
help